and you also asked me what is the
science after the bell curve and the
short answer is there's not much new
work but whatever work there is supports
the idea that there still are group
differences
it's arguable whether those differences
have diminished at all or not
and there is still a major problem in
underperformance ins for school
achievement
for many uh disadvantaged and minority
students and there so far is no way to
fix it uh what do we do with this
information what uh is this is this now
a task now we'll talk about the future
um on the neuroscience and the biology
side but in terms of this information as
a society in the public policy in the
political space in the social space What
do we do with this information I've
thought a lot about this the first step
is to have people interested in policy
understand what the data actually show
to pay attention to intelligence data
you can read policy papers about
education and using your word processor
you can search for the word intelligence
you can search a a 20 000 Word document
in a second and find out the word
intelligence does not appear anywhere
in most discussions about what to do
about achievement gaps I'm not talking
about test gaps I'm talking about actual
achievement gaps in schools which
everyone agrees is a problem
the word intelligence doesn't appear
among educators
that's fascinating as a matter of fact
in California
there has been tremendous controversy
about recent attempts to revise the
curriculum for math in high schools
and we had a Stanford professor of
Education who was running this review
assert there's no such thing as Talent
of mathematical Talent
and she wanted to get rid of the
advanced classes in math because you
know not everyone could do that
now of course this has been very
controversial they've retreated somewhat
but the idea that a university Professor
was in charge of this who believes
not that there's no
Talent
that it doesn't exist
this is rather shocking let alone the
complete absence of intelligence data by
the way let me tell you something about
what the intelligence data show let's
take race out of it
uh even though the origins of these
studies uh were were a long time ago
and I'm blocking on the name of the
report the Coleman report was a famous
report about education and they measured
all kinds of variables about schools
about teachers and they looked at
academic achievement as an outcome
and they found the most predictive
variables of Education outcome were the
variables the student brought with him
or her into the school essentially their
ability
and that when you combine the school and
the teacher variables together
quality of the school the funding of the
school the quality of the teachers their
education you put all the teacher and
school variables together it barely
accounted for 10 of the variance
and this has been replicated now
you know so the best research we have
shows that school variables and teacher
variables together account for about 10
percent of student academic achievement
now you want to have some policy on
improving academic achievement how much
money do you want to put into teacher
education how much money you want to put
into the quality of of the school
administration you know who you can ask
you can ask the Gates Foundation
because they spent a tremendous amount
of money doing that
and they us at the end of it because
they're measurement people they want to
you know they want to know the data they
found it had no impact at all and
they've kind of pulled out of of that
kind of program
so oh boy
let me ask let me ask you this is me
talking but there's
just the two of us well just the two of
us but I'm gonna say uh some funny and
ridiculous things so
you're surely are not approving of it uh
but there's a movie called Clerks
I mean you probably I've seen it I've
seen it yeah there's a funny scene in
there where uh a lovely couple are
talking about the number of previous
sexual partners they had
and
um uh the the woman says that I believe
she just had a handful like two or three
or something like that sexual partners
but then she also mentioned
um that she
um what's that called uh fellatio what's
the scientific but she went you know
give a [ __ ] to uh 37 guys I believe
it is and uh so that has to do with the
truth
so sometimes knowing the truth
can get in the way of a successful
relationship of Love of some of the
human flourishing
and that's seems to me that's at the
core here that facing some kind of
truth that's not able to be changed
it makes it difficult to sort of
is limiting as opposed to empowering
that's the concern if you sort of test
for intelligence and lay the data out
it feels like you will give up on
certain people
you will you'll you'll sort of start
binning people's like well this is this
person is like let's focused on the
average people or let's focus on the
very intelligent people that's the
concern and and there's a kind of
intuition that if we just don't measure
and we don't use that data that we would
treat everybody equal and give everybody
uh equal opportunity
if we have the data in front of us we're
likely to miss uh distribute the amount
of sort of attention we allocate
resources we allocate uh allocate to
people that's that's probably the
concern it's a realistic concern
and but I think it's a misplaced concern
if you want to fix the problem
if you want to fix the problem you have
to know what the problem is yes now let
me let me tell you this let's go back to
the bell curve for not the bell curve
but the normal distribution yes
16 percent of the population on average
has an IQ under 85.
which means their very heart if you have
an IQ under 85 it's very hard to find
gainful employment at a salary
that sustains you at least minimally in
Modern Life
okay not impossible but it's very
difficult
sixteen percent of the population of the
United States is about 51 or 52 million
people with IQs under 85.
this is not a small issue
14 million children have IQs under 85.
is this something we want to ignore
does this have any what is the Venn
diagram between you know when you have
people with IQs under 85 and you have
achievement in school or achievement in
life
there's a lot of overlap there this is
why to go back to the IQ pill if there
were a way
to shift
that curve toward the higher end that
would have a big impact